j'aime le julien d'après j'aime le
julien tout le temps je suis bien qu un
des rares animateurs avec passé sur
trois gros chaîne tf1 ouais m6 et ses
huit teintes et france 2 on va dire tv
c'est exactement à faire qu'on va faire
tf1 m6 et 8 ou le reste est ce que tu
peux me dire quelle chaîne paye le mieux
tf1 c'est 8 m6 et tf1 tf1
sherritt non ces 8e situé sur tf1
c'était des cachets sur ces huit des
comprimés
c'est là où les patrons seul est plus
sympa tf1 m6 et 8 franchement là c'est
hyper compliqué c'était trois styles
différents il y avait non moi je vous
entends des super bien avec etienne
mougeotte mais vraiment moche et
aujourd'hui patron cfa rachat d'or a été
mon but j'ai vendu des concepts en 40
secondes en voiture il faut des heures
des semaines j'ai entraîné j'ai une idée
sur une émission sur les mariages vendus
je te raconte un jour je te fais
confiance et je portais comme ça ça va
faire plaisir limitations que vous
voulez porter tout se fait tellement je
savais que moi j'ai un gros regret c'est
dur c'est de ne pas avoir été et je vous
jure un jour je l' ai vu et il m'a dit
il m'a dit je si à l'époque je t'aurais
fait venir sur tf1 c'est sûr ça c'est si
j'étais dégoûté parce que vrai
rochelaise voilà je l'adoré c'est le nom
qu'ils jouent mais c'est lui à ce que je
ne fais pas une comparaison mais c'est
lui qui dit faux la gaffe c'est lui qui
a dit il faut arroser le mox est un
visionnaire c'est lui qui m'a viré et
c'est un vrai métier
un jour mon voyant au grand concours 11
à 2,6 me l'a dit le lendemain en lice
mais qu'il a quand même quelque chose
il doit pouvoir être très chiant mais il
a vraiment un truc 12 ans est témoin ce
à dessein de mes grands regrets oui donc
où les collègues de travail sont les
plus grands c'est plus sympa les plus
sympas oh bah c'est bien dans ces cas là
je veux dire c'est 8 pour une raison
très simple c'est que c'est pas
tellement non mais c'est vrai même si
j'ai pas eu vraiment de bons danger mes
copains rtl bien sûr mais là j'ai vécu
pendant quatre ans le délire des
différentes émissions donc pas ou là là
où il ya le plus de jalousie entre les
animateurs se dirait que c'était
peut-être plutôt côté de tf1 où il y
avait de gros et gourlé pas encore il y
avait 1 c'était quand même celui qui
avait le plus grand nombre il y avait
bien eu du lourd y avait du 2 chavanne
du foucault du sabatier du sébastien du
castaldi quand il est arrivé aussi les
fêtes de la place qu'on va plus chez moi
je me rappellerai toujours en un samedi
après-midi telle qu'elle s'était franck
firmin guion qui était directeur des
programmes julien je dois annoncer un
truc gardes pour toi c'est sous embargo
qu'est ce qui se passe là vous avez
vendu la chaîne non non non benjamin
castaldi va nous rejoindre et super g 8
mois ils m'ont appelé et m'a dit c'est
sous embargo
benjamin castaldi va nous rejoindre ce
connard non non j'adore moi moi moi je
qu'il voulait pas que je vienne à tf1
bref qui me parlait de mes yeux il
disait tout le temps mais c'est vrai
mais en même temps vous êtes venus en
fait ces jeunes quand il partait en fait
exactement va vous donner toujours quand
les gens partout là où tu es le plus
heureux j'ai été heureux partout j'étais
là je m'éclate vraiment je remercie
mille fois même si je me laissais faire
ça j'ai vécu des années fantastiques ici
voilà cédé un petit peu et des
discothèques des années 80 3 5 3
ambiances tf1 m6 ses huit doigts là tu
vois tu m'as terminer ta carrière ou là
je pense que tel que c'est parti comme
ça je pense que ça peut être assez 8
meur n'est jamais
[Applaudissements]
j'ai senti chez le contrat entre dans
cette émission